the 90 of you
that are standing there is a substantial
chance that you have not even lived half
your life there are people sitting here
stressed that they [ __ ] it up they
missed their time they misplayed it they
shouldn't have and they've got the
majority of their life left
that blows my mind and the timing was
very
good for this talk
because literally just 24 hours ago
i was very much back to my
entrepreneurial routes
i was in atlantic city new jersey for
the last three days
and i was set up at a table and i was
selling trading cards
sports cards and sports stickers the way
i learned business when i was 11 12 13
years old but unlike
30 years ago when i was doing it
the majority of the cards that i was
selling the last three days
were v friends cards
which is
which is an intellectual property that
i'm building
and that intellectual property those 250
characters
are very much the sesame street pokemon
characters
that i'm going to use for the next 45-50
years
to really talk about mindset
and perspective the things that i've
been doing as gary vee have been
really fun for me
but i'm one human being one man i also
have a very specific style that i
communicate and live and that works for
many but it doesn't work for everybody
watch this how many people here by show
of hands
the first time you ever saw me on the
internet
thought
that i was a jerk or an [ __ ] raise
your hands
look hurts
but i'm incredibly self-aware i
understand why
i get it
and for
the you know the way the world actually
works luckily for me that the truth
always wins in the end and i'm able to
persevere
eventually make the right piece of
content at the right time that fits for
somebody but i'm also aware that for
some people because of the cursing or
for some other reason
i'll never be able to be the person that
speaks to them about the true virtues
that matter
to live a joyful life
and thus
many years ago i decided i'm going to
build an entire universe of characters
to do that
so that i can start from people when
they're three years old all the way to
their 99
that's not what i want to talk to you
about
but those characters
enable and represent the things that i
want to talk to you about the things
that i want to talk about
are the
things that are hard
on a journey to achieve happiness and
joy fulfillment whatever one tries to
achieve
you know i've been thinking about
something a lot lately which is
a lot of my friends
and acquaintances always ask me why i go
so hard why i'm pushing so hard
you know because i'm very fortunate at
this point in my life that i've put some
wins on the board i've achieved a couple
of things it always
reminds me how surprised i am
when people ask me this question
it reminds me how many people
genuinely believe
that financial status is the north star
their question is almost always baked
in the framework of how much money i've
acquired or have
and i always
ponder that it's always so interesting
to me
how the data the math
is black and white
on this issue
there is absolutely no correlation
to one's
wealth
that maps their happiness
this is
black and white
we continue to have a world that is
confused
that money buys happiness
it continues to be what someone who's
hurting
thinks
is the potion or the anecdote to fix it
yet
we have unlimited amounts of hundreds of
millions of people who prove otherwise
we must
start there
the concept that you're going to buy
your way to happiness
is the biggest falsity in human society
and we must stop
doing that
[Applause]
thank
you was getting a little annoying
this is a message that's extremely
challenging for me
to be the person who delivers it
almost always when i say that 20 of the
comments are easy for you to say
that's because most people consume my
content today
what my high school friends and college
friends and friends of my 20 know
is i was arguably happier
at 29 making 45 000 a year than i am
today
the process
of doing something you actually like
is my great
addiction the fact that i am able to
actually wake up
day in and day out day in and day out
sleep easily for seven eight hours a
night and wake up genuinely excited
while always being prepared to grab my
phone
and know that i have a problem in my 300
person singapore office or something
happened in l.a or one of the other 17
businesses that i'm associated with are
in trouble i sit on top of almost 3 000
employees
and two very large businesses actively
as the ceo
and then on the board of four others and
heavily invested in others and
many other things i'm involved with and
family and this and that
i have plenty going on
but the fact that i do what i want to do
enables all of it to work
this
is grounded in something that is the
absolute answer for this entire arena
the one thing i can absolutely speak on
that fundamentally touches every person
here
is the relationship between self-esteem
and insecurity
all
of the things that you do
are based on this
if you look at what's really been going
on
with people for a very long time
why
when one is sold fear
that they believe it
versus when they're sold fear that they
don't
why so few people
have a framework of believing in
optimism
versus protecting themselves with
cynicism
why people lack patience
i can tell you right now that for the
majority of people in this room that
want something to happen
the biggest flaw
in their mental framework and
perspective
is their lack of patience
it is why i make so much content
around people that are 22
25
35
40 and laughing
and joking
and trying to some way somehow
communicate to them that they are
extremely young how many people here are
under 50 years old please stand up stand
up
stand up
i want everybody looking around
under 50
first of all
let's clap up
for the over 50 crowd that's sitting and
respect our elders
[Applause]
now
now
love that now
for the 90 of you
that are standing
there is a substantial chance
that you have not even lived half your
life
if you are under 40 continue to stand
please sit 40 to 50. i'll sit as well
for this crew
given where modern medicine is
there's a dark horse chance
that you haven't lived a third of your
life
think about that there are people
sitting here stressed that they [ __ ]
it up
they missed their time
they misplayed it
they shouldn't have
and they've got the majority of their
life left
that blows my mind
it really does
every day of my life that blows my mind
sit down if you're over 30. 30 and under
continue to stand
for you [ __ ]
[Applause]
you know
i had this saying i used to do
where i would say i would rip my arm off
to switch with you
because there's so much time so much
opportunity
but now with tick-tock and you can clip
things people have really taken that out
of context so i try not to say it as
much
but my friends if you're standing right
now
for you even to begin
to deploy anxiety against your own self
judge your own self that you have not
done you did not accomplish you were
unable
is
completely unacceptable
[Applause]
you have
literally
the rest of your life in front of you
you have foundation as a matter of fact
if i actually with all the depths of my
heart
if i was actually able to give you the a
piece of advice if i had one though i
think everyone's situation is different
i would try to get you to just enjoy
the next 10 years more
not go as hard as you think i would tell
you to go
because you have that much time
you have that much time
most of society's rules
and traditions are based on
when people were dying at 50 years old
most of the rules of when you should get
married and what you should do and what
you should have accomplished is
literally based on the last century's
dna
you are so young
[Applause]
you have
every opportunity
technology is exploding at a speed where
your life can change in a minute on a
decision
and literally literally the only thing
that is [ __ ] you up is you worry
about what other people think about your
life whether that's your parents
your friends
me
[Applause]
please stop doing that
wear crazy rose suits
i like it it's very nice
do random [ __ ] try new things you have
your whole life in front of you i i
couldn't be happier for you if you're
standing right now you have a hundred
years to live that's actually how it's
gonna work out for you and you need to
start acting like it sit down
[Applause]
it's real
let's talk about why
you actually
listen to somebody else's point of view
on your life
let's talk about why
somebody else's
point of view
on your life
is something you're willing to accept
i am fascinated by people's ability
to take strangers
comments
on a social media post
and allow it
to make them upset
[Applause]
you post something
and you're happy to post it
and then somebody literally leaves a
comment
that you're
unattractive
you're stupid
like literally
high school and junior high teasing
and your entire day
sometimes week
sometimes month
is completely ruined
by a human being
who is on the other side on their phone
who is hurting so much with their own
life
that the need
for them to make it palpable
is for them to take time to go to other
people's lives and try to tear them down
to make themselves feel better
this is what i call
[Applause]
let's stop clapping so i can finish this
one
this is what i call a circle of
insecurity
a circle
of insecurity
the concept
that that is happening
is not facebook's fault
is not instagram's fault
it's not tick-tock's fault
it's not
we have become
infatuated
with blaming the platforms
for our own shortcomings
until
humans
decide to lean into accountability
and stop blaming
platforms
and politicians
people will continue to be unhappy
[Applause]
let me tell you something that is the
most interesting secret
of all time i'm so this is my newest
thought that i've not finished i'm still
in the laboratory of my own brain and
heart
but i'm gonna
try it here in germany
i've been sleeping on something for
about six months
and i'm really excited about it because
it's super true i'm just trying to get
fully there
so it just in my soul because i think
you have a sense i only know how to
communicate in improv form there is no
slides there is no deck
there's only
this and
and so i often don't talk about things
until it's fully ingrained but i think
i'm there
and it's something i want to tell you
that is very much
in line with what i've just been talking
about which is this concept of
who we are how we roll why are we
affected by what and how
where do we go and how it's always been
the same thing
as if
people were unhappy before social media
as if
right
i think everyone here
at this conference
needs to leave
knowing one very important thing
this one
very important thing
and that is
you
are not tricking
anyone
you
are not tricking anyone
people
continue to live life
posturing
sharing photos
that they're so happy and crushing it
having dinner and saying
everything's great
my favorite one
buying
[ __ ] that they can't afford
to make it seem like they can afford it
and living basically their entire life
as if the [ __ ]
that they're trying to project
is actually working
think about how many times
you've gone home
after being with three or four friends
and have had a conversation with one
other friend about a different friend
who was posturing but you both knew it
wasn't true
think about how the world's currency is
actually working
the
real obvious thing to me
is if we all knew
that the only people you ever trick
are the only people you don't want to be
hanging out with in the first place
i think a lot of things in our world
would change
it is time
[Applause]
my friends
why
why are we trying to impress people so
much
why
for what
we must
really work
on not allowing
outside validation
to dictate our lives you
love yourself is real the problem is
people don't love themselves
the reason everyone's trying to do it is
they don't
because they've decided because it was
put into their brain
that their worth is based on things that
are very surface level
their appearance
their bank account
and lots of other dumb [ __ ]
we have such an opportunity as the world
is changing see everyone's paying
attention right now and they're focusing
on
the
media landscape changing and the
negatives that come along with it
the politics
the nationalism they focus on that what
they don't realize is in parallel the
platforms also create the opposite
this is the first time since the
printing press where we can collectively
change the perspective
of how the world works
it's true
[Applause]
but the confusion
for almost everyone is very similar
which is
there is a relationship in the world
between being selfish
and being selfless
now this is where it gets very
interesting for me
too many people feel
as if it's one or the other
one of the biggest challenges in the
world today
is that people think the world is about
ore
one of the biggest challenges in the
world today is that people think the
world is about or
it's this or that
it's them or us
it's this or that
when the entire world is always and
people are so obsessed
with things to be black and white
when the world is purely gray
and so
what i'm very very fascinated by
is everyone here
genuinely
taking a step back and having a
conversation with themselves
about them being selfish
and them being selfless
most people's relationship with those
two things is an extreme challenge
some people are inherently selfish and
they struggle with it because they think
it's bad
some people are absolutely selfless
and they see it as tremendously noble
but when they deliver on it on too big
of an extreme
they create
subconscious resentment to everyone that
they're bringing value to and then it
manifests
in vulnerabilities later down the line
if you are able to actually understand
selfish and selfless behavior and find
balance within both of those for
yourself you can start creating an
incredible mental framework to be able
to navigate the world if everybody was
able to bleed a little more selfless if
they were
definingly selfish
and for the selfless people
if they weren't so noble on paper and
could understand that they need to be
selfish to themselves to be able to be
selfless
we could have a much happier world
please leave with that today for sure
[Applause]
it's a big one
[Applause]
for me
everything i've ever wanted selfishly
is happening
because of my aggressive selflessness
a funny thing happens people always talk
about i want to build a brand like you
gary i want to build a brand i'm like
okay
they're like i want to build a community
i'm like okay i'm a very weird dude and
what that means is
a lot of times i'll go and audit what
that person's doing
when i tell you 99 out of 100 times when
somebody's crying about not building a
big enough profile that when i go on
their account
that 98
of their content is selfish
as if you are entitled to followers
as if you're entitled to people buying
your [ __ ]
as if you're entitled to likes just by
existence just by posting you should be
getting it
the entitlement in our society is
extraordinary
the accountability
is equally
extraordinary
in the negative
the sheer lack of accountability in the
human race today is staggering
we are so good at telling
everybody and the world what's wrong
with everybody else besides ourselves
we love
to point fingers
we hate a [ __ ]
[Applause]
thumb there is
nothing
there is nothing
more obvious to me than that happiness
starts with accountability
my life is happy
because i think everything in my life is
my fault
all of it
it is the most liberating truth of all
time of course i'm logically
understanding that there's other people
that there's other variables that
there's things i don't control
but i'm completely in control to what i
do
how many people here have employees
raise your hand
raise your hands higher employees
here's here's my favorite one
about people that employ people they're
the boss they have employees they sit
around
and complain about their employees 24 7
or often
and they're in control of firing them
fire them
yeah by the way
you know what was the best part of that
line
none of the bosses wanted to clap
we suck
currently at accountability
we suck at it
and for a lot of people here
it's the answer to the trivia question
when you actually understand it it's
actually fundamentally true
you are capable of doing anything you
are capable of firing your employees
you are capable of breaking up
in your relationship
you are capable of moving to another
town
another country you are capable of
selling your home and downgrading your
home to a smaller home so you're always
not tight on money you
are capable
of all of it
but we don't like that
we like
to blame all our problems
on putin
[Applause]
bad day at work
[ __ ] putin
bad day at home facebook the algorithm
and the dictators
are not impacting your day-to-day
anywhere close to what you've decided
your lack of accountability
is dictating
this is a very
focal point of the conversation
we must understand this
everything you talk about
gratitude empathy kindness all things
that i live on
they all come from me thinking
everything's my fault
they all come from me knowing i have
control
everybody when they get into the
accountability and control game
immediately much of this audience starts
thinking to the counterpoint
they immediately start thinking to the
counterpoint
the natural human spirit for most people
when told everything is your fault you
are in control of everything will start
giving you 800 answers to why that's not
true for them
and that's how they're missing the point
when i brought up earlier sell if you
are tight on money
and you own a home
sell your home and live in a shittier
home
do you know how many people do that on
earth
no one
do you know how logical what i just said
is you were tight on cash you were
really struggling you own a fairly nice
home and your mortgage situation you
have an asset
and you will not sell it
to live in a lesser home
because you worry about what people
think about that move
[Applause]
my favorite chess move to this debate is
like but gary i can't do that to my kids
my counterpoint is that's the best [ __ ]
you can do for your kids
[Music]
we now live in a universe where one of
the biggest reasons we have so much
anxiety i love when people by the way
can we keep that light on i know you
guys are doing some production but
seeing all these beautiful faces really
gets me going
really
one of the biggest elephants in the room
in our entire world this is an american
a german a south africa this is a global
you know one of the great things of
having fans everywhere in the world and
reading all the dms it's all the same
[ __ ]
it's all the same [ __ ] of course there's
massive cultural differences and it's
interesting because you have to really
do the work
but at all when you when you file it
down
when you bake it when you melt it it's
all the same [ __ ]
it's cultural up here but just keep
blending it it's all the same here
and when i tell you
when i say
moving to a lesser nice house and giving
your kids some adversity is the best
thing
the elephant in the world the elephant
not in the room the elephant in the
world today is for the last 30 years it
became popular culture
to raise our children
and do everything we could
to demonize losing
and protect them from literally
everything thus
creating 20 and 30 year olds
who are basically zoo animals we kept
them in the zoo
and then we tell them to go into the
wild
and then a [ __ ] lion eats them in an
hour
[Applause]
and my favorite part of the whole thing
that i'm watching is you have people in
their 50s the boomers
and older gen x
my crew by the way which nobody talks
about as if gen x doesn't exist it's
just millennial boomers like yo what the
[ __ ] we're here
you have boomers
the people that i [ __ ] i love young
millennials and gen z i think they just
understand they have way more options
and i think people [ __ ] on them i do
think
that we did wrong by them i do think
that they shouldn't blame their parents
because that lacks accountability
there's a lot to this but let me say
this the funniest [ __ ] of the whole
thing
is we are watching boomers run around
the world [ __ ] on these kids
when they're the ones who [ __ ]
parented
them like gary i mean i had a friend the
other day he's like gary my kid
my kid is like
can't [ __ ] like he's he's a mess like
he's like scared of everything that i'm
like
that's because you gave him a trophy
when his team came in eighth [ __ ]
place
now it's super fun to laugh
at the kids
let me promise including myself every
person in this arena
has a version of that in them as well
this is a game of insecurity of course
you're insecure at 28 years old when
your parents behavior their whole life
showed you that they didn't believe that
you could
they didn't believe that you could you
start believing that you can't either
if they're protecting you in every step
of the way
they're telling you i don't think you
can do it
thus you believe it
we have that as 30 year olds and 40 year
olds and 50 year olds and 60 year olds
and 70 year olds i know this
because what i do for a living
is read what people say
at a scale that would make this
collective room
head spin it's what i do for a living
six
seven eight hours a day i am consuming
ungodly amounts of information on how
people are reacting to things what they
think what they believe and then i go
deeper into my own content and other
content that i see behind the scenes on
the world is this close to being happy
and it feels like it's this close from
being happy
and this is why i'm so motivated
i'm so motivated because almost
everybody is sitting around dinner
tables saying dumb [ __ ] like it's never
been this bad
i don't need to remind anybody in this
room it's been worse
this
world is actually dangerously close
it is
it's one of those things when you know
it's like so many stories and so many
things in life where it seems so far
away but it was right there
the reason i get inspired to take
overnight red-eye flights to an event
like this
is this is a lot of people that know
it's this close
this is a lot of people that decide on a
weekend
that they want to commit
to making themselves happier for
themselves the people around them and
the people that they're bringing into
the world
it is actually scary
how many people are this close
the part that's left
is we have to talk about the [ __ ] that
people don't want to talk about
it's fun to talk about the fufi stuff
it's not fun to say
everything you're upset about is 100
your fault
it's awesome to think about
you putting in the commitment to give a
[ __ ] to come to something like this on a
saturday
it's not as fun to say what the [ __ ] are
you doing here on a saturday
do you understand
let me say it again
it is awesome that you are making the
commitment to be here on a saturday
the bigger question is why are you here
the reason is
every piece of the puzzle is not there
yet the missing piece of the puzzle
is not the stuff that you hear every day
the stuff you think about every day if
it would be it'd be done
the missing part is the part that you're
not willing to look at yourself in the
mirror for let me be
vulnerable and tell you mine
now we're getting it
now we are getting
it three four five years ago i started
having a conversation with myself
on what i'm trying to push you to do
with me right now
which is
if i'm so [ __ ] great
why are there people that exist on earth
that don't love me
and i don't mean the people that um [ __ ]
this [ __ ] that on a 30-second video and
they're like this guy's atrocious that
doesn't even register for me that's
appropriate that's the way it should be
i'm talking about people that have
worked for me
and so i had to go through a real
journey
over the last five six years and it
culminated with the book that i put out
last year where i had to talk in depth
about the fact that by far the biggest
weakness in my life professionally and
personally
is that i am so
positive
so optimistic
and on stage i'm incredibly candarous as
i've been so far
but in my real life
one-on-one
i am atrocious at conflict
i hate
being the person that starts anything
that looks like an altercation
when there is an altercation i use my
incredible communication talents to get
out of it or divert everyone from it
immediately
and because of that i was incredibly not
candarous with anybody in my life
not
i mean everybody in my life
which was fine because i'm incredibly
good at picking people to be around me
and thus it worked most the time
but you don't get to pick all of your
family and you don't always have it
right and thus
the biggest weakness in my career and
life has been my inability to be
cancerous
i have always looked at somebody that
shoots it straight as using it as an
excuse to be mean
i grew up in an environment where one
side of my family was incredibly
candarous but the candor was always
negativity and combative so i didn't
understand that candor is quite healthy
as a package
but they were filling it with poison and
thus i demonized the package along with
the
poison when i tell you my life
is dramatically better
dramatically better that i am
remarkably better as a ceo today that
vaynerx
has doubled in revenue in two and a half
years
solely
on the back of me being dramatically
more candarous and when i tell you
if i was a one out of ten
four years ago which i was
and 10 is like where we all want to be
as i stand in front of you here today
i'm a five
and from one to five
my life is 800 times better
not fun for me
that's not that was hard for me what you
understand you have to understand is the
thing that i'm trying to accomplish in
this talk today you don't see it i did
not see it
i'm [ __ ] all i do is think about this
[ __ ]
all i do is think about this [ __ ] for
the last 40 years of my life literally
since i've been a child all i think
about is this [ __ ] they used to be
different words
you know the feel i remember my teenage
years i knew i had something weird i'm
like i have the feel i don't know what
the [ __ ] it meant but what it meant was
my intuition
is weird i believe in all sorts of [ __ ]
like ghosts and [ __ ] everything just
because of my feel you guys half of you
can't listen to my podcast because i'm
always interrupting everybody
because i already know what they're
going to say
and with all of that
because i'm a human being i was
completely blind to why people would be
upset with me but it was very logical
i would literally see employees on a
thursday and be like hey ron good to see
you keep up the great work have the best
weekend
and on tuesday ron would come in and be
like ryan you're fired
and ron would be like what the [ __ ]
because i would tell him on thursday
have a good weekend da da da what i
didn't tell him was for the last two and
a half years i was super frustrated with
ron because he sucks
but i didn't have candor as a weapon
everybody here has that too
and i didn't see it and i'm very in tune
my question is why are you here on a
saturday
every one of you
needs to completely take
the thing
i didn't see it
and yet i knew it
i didn't see it
and yet i knew it
you understand
[Applause]
this
and i and can you do you guys have a
good camera let's see can you
it's gonna go away but i just got
goosebumps because i'm about to tell you
something
my number one goal in life let alone
being a ceo
is to eliminate fear
[Applause]
the thing i'm most proud of even
emotional as i sit here right now is
that for my sister and my brother and my
parents
i lived my life
to take on all the stress
that i was capable that i have the
ability to take it all on
i
am so proud
that i am great
at eliminating fear
for my family
then i started doing it for my employees
and today where i am on my journey
i do it for many people
it's something i'm very proud of
[Applause]
we're getting to the meat of this talk
i'm very proud of that
however
remember earlier when i told you
you can't trick
people
you're tricking no one
the lowest point of my professional
career
by a country mile nothing is even close
is when it was very clear to me
off of a series of meetings
that my inability to give candor
though on the facade
led to an incredible culture
there was
my senior leaders not my junior people
but my most senior leaders
were scared
because they didn't know exactly where
they sat with me
my lack of candor
was tricking nobody that was spending
those meetings with me
that was the low point
for me
i need you to understand
we've got this time together this is it
i'm with you right now
i need you to understand
you know why you're here on a saturday
you don't want to tell anybody
you don't even want to tell the person
you're sitting next to who's the closest
to you in the world
but they already know
the quicker
you get naked
and tell the world what you suck at
is the quicker
you don't need to come here on a
saturday
because let me tell you
somebody
who was living it at 85 or 90 without
the candor part and now is living it at
95 percent
do you know why i'm nice do you know why
i'm nice
it's because i'm happy
i don't need anything from you i want
nothing from you i need nothing from you
financially i definitely don't need
anything from you emotionally do you
know why people are not nice because
they do
they're grasping at straws
they're they've caught a tiger by the
tail and have a relationship with a nice
person or they have a nice boss they're
scared every single day for that person
to leave because that person is the
energy of balance because they
themselves are super hurt inside they're
hurt
because they haven't put the poison into
the world
they've demonized therapy so they don't
do that
if they've done that they definitely
don't tell normal people
they
peacock and hide behind money
behind status
behind things
my friends
the world is this close
the reason it feels so far away
is occasionally people come around and
realize how much fear works
how much demonizing others works
it makes people feel safe for a second
it is the least sustainable thing in the
world
it is the least sustainable thing in the
world you know how i know this
i
was an atrocious student
but there was one class i was always
good at
history
i never understood why
and then finally in my 30s i realized oh
because my entrepreneurial spirit knew
that i would need it to recognize
pattern recognition today
many people
[ __ ] on me or laugh at me because i
believe in nfts
in a decade
in a decade
in a decade
i'm gonna laugh at them you know how i
know this history
in 1996 i told anybody that would listen
to me that the internet was a very good
thing
in 1999 when the stock market crashed
everybody said the internet was a fad
in 2005
in 2007 i was in germany three times for
three different talks
talking about social media
how twitter was phenomenal and i was on
a panel with debating somebody
and they said to the crowd how many
people think twitter is stupid and
everybody raised their hand
everybody
and the person interviewing me said gary
why is twitter so important and i said
because people are going to tweet that
they're walking their dog
everybody laughed
not at it
at me
the reporter rightfully said that sounds
ludicrous who cares if somebody's
walking their dog my reply
everyone
i suck at almost everything
thank you
it's true
it's people are so confused how the
world works everybody in this room
pretty much sucks at almost everything
except a couple things
i suck at almost everything but the one
thing that has been with me
since i was a child
when i listened to my late grandma's
stories about me from zero to seven or
my mother's it's very clear
that dna is a remarkably powerful thing
i suck at almost everything except one
thing
i know you
collectively as well as any person that
works
on earth
i understand people i do it comes to me
it's natural to me and i'm so grateful
for it because i have such deep wants
for it to be good
i'm in such a good place and i want you
to be in a good place and it's a lot a
lot easier than people realize it seems
so daunting
but it's kind of like working out you
know
figuring it out mentally is like
figuring it out physically
here is how you get physically more fit
you eat
healthier
and you go to the gym
i know you're trying to stop her from
eating the popcorn keep eating it it's
delicious
that was the best i'm like you eat
healthier she went in for the popcorn
and friends like stop
you literally
eat better ratios of protein versus
carbs and sugar
and you go to the gym
and you get your heart helped up
and you use your muscles and you build
up your leg it is actually
remarkably simple
yet so [ __ ] hard to execute
with this [ __ ]
you want to win this game
tell everybody what you suck at
tell them
[Applause]
instead of talking in thesis
i'm going to give you a piece of
homework
i want everybody to leave this
conference
i want you to take your cell phone
i want you to put it into your face
and i want you to speak
for 15 minutes
or 3 or 9 or 17
and say [ __ ] you've never said before
that you have no interest in people
knowing
[Applause]
you want to get value out of this
conference you want to accomplish what
you came here for
i'm going to ask you once again to do
the following i want you to leave this
conference preferably right the [ __ ] now
like actually get up and leave right now
take your phone
and tell the world what you're not good
at
what you are not proud that you have
done what you are scared of and why
and post it on every social network you
have
and
if you don't and i know there's some
people like yes thank god i don't have
social media
for all of you it's even harder you take
that video you go into your contacts
you start at a
arn anderson
and you finish
sending it tonight to charlie sanderson
and you send it to everybody in between
who in here is interested in doing that
now
let's stop right there
eight percent are
interested of the eight percent who just
said they're interested
98 of them will not do it
i
am going to fly back home tonight
smiling
because i know three of you are
three
three
three
what i just said
is [ __ ] impossible
i know
it's hard
it's really hard
but it's the answer
everything that's not work my man are
you going to do it
i'll see you there
make your video you do it on stage let's
go
[Music]
[Applause]
let's see
let's see if we believe him
[Applause]
you ready
i'm ready
i i
i can hear you
we can hear you guys we get nice and
close go ahead
um
i feel fear yes but i will do it anyway
let's go
what's your name
lawrence florence
hello answer
his password is 1097.
yes
so i i have tik tok instagram linkedin
we need your whole video we need yes yes
we're gonna have to chop it up here we
go
okay okay yes we're gonna gather your
thoughts i know how to do it yes yes
so
my biggest hero what
not only your biggest fear i want you to
talk right now about what you're not
good at who you've let down
what you're bad at who you've hurt yes
what you're scared of everything go okay
start with your name my name is lawrence
uh i'm i'm gary vee lawrence is in front
of all of these people
yes man yes
yes
so lawrence
lawrence is making this video because my
hypothesis is that our secrets
our insecurities
the things we're not transparent about
are the cancer of our life and it's why
we're not as happy as we can be so he's
about to make a video that i hope
all 8 billion people on earth make
eventually
and we're gonna we're going to judge him
on how much we actually believe him
he's going to tell us
everything bad go ahead
um
yes i will do it
i i feel how old are you i'm 20. where
do you live
in austria vienna with whom
sorry do you live alone with your
parents with my mom with your mom yes no
and where's your dad my dad lives
20 meters next to there they're
separated yes they're separated how old
were you when they separated
three years ago three years ago yes but
it was the best thing that ever happened
because my
ever no no no uh the relationship the
relationship to my father was better
than yes i think that this could be the
point um i judged my father because he
worked a lot and
he didn't took time for me
and i said yes dad i want you to leave
home or i want to um yes to go away
because my mom had the role of my mom
and dad yes and so i when when they they
were divorced my mom went away from home
but
in this time i was i was angry at my dad
because he never asked me how i am and
he never asked me any question and then
it was the first time he did it and i
was like who is this man or why why is
he asking me this and then i said
please this is so confusing i don't want
you here because it's not normal to me
yes but he's my dad yes and when when
they got divorced
we
had a better relationship because my
heart was open yes i was hurt but my
heart was open i said
i i love you you're my dad i'm
i love you so much and we talked openly
and i said but i was hurt because you
didn't ask me um how i am
and i accepted it and i
i'm i'm yes i love him and i told him
that
so
yes everything got better because i
i knew who he was now and not in the
past it was okay to me all right that
was nice to talk about your dad now
let's talk about what you're not doing
well what i'm not doing well yes what
are you not good i am impatient why
because i i have the feeling that i
should be here
why oh i am here i am here yes
so i'm proud of myself but you didn't
earn it
what but you didn't earn it
i earned it you did not
why do you feel you should be here when
you didn't earn it yes i have a message
to spread yes that's the reason but
how many tick tocks instagram posts
and youtube shorts do you make it once a
day once a day if you want to be in
front of crowds like this do you think
one post a day is going to get you there
i should do four
yes
okay
yes
because i have a message you mean yes i
understand but this is luck
you being on this stage is luck
me being on this stage is earned yes yes
do you understand i understand so what
what are you telling your friends that
are it's not true
what are you today yes telling your
friends
that isn't true
what are you communicating to them about
yourself
that you think is not true i'm a really
honest person okay so i tell them hey i
suck dead or what what do you think is
my problem now what did i do wrong to
you so i have no regrets
in front of them so i i speak really um
apparently there is good yes and what
about with your what about to yourself
yes i'm sometimes i put myself down and
say i'm not worth it or i i don't have
any message to spread or something like
that because
the world tells me i'm not okay how i am
and
sometimes i believe this and i would say
that's the biggest regret i have because
it's not true because i i can decide who
i am and
that's the reason why i'm here
why i listen to you
yes
what about
there's a lot of people watching this on
your social now yes who do you want to
say sorry to
who have you hurt yes and why
i have one person
in in school it was um he was he didn't
shower
and i i didn't bully him but
you made fun of him a little bit a
little bit yes
yes yes i i stand to that it's okay for
me what's his name his name is timon
his name is timon but i had an open
conversation with him as i said i'm a
very honest person and i cleared it up
it's very nice but it's good to see uh
good to say again so he knows that i
love him and it was just because of my
insecurity that i hurt him because i
don't i didn't want to be the one who
gets
bullied in school so i
i jumped on the train and did it
against him say that one more time
because everyone's clapping because you
didn't want to be the one that was going
to get picked on yes you saw someone who
was potentially weaker because of his
showering situation and you jumped on
that train to deflect so it wasn't you
yes and it happened to me also
and
i was the little kid and i was always
the best friend of the girls and they
said [ __ ] about me and
i think it's a yes you know it's a
security reason why i said okay i don't
want to be this anymore and i bullied
him but
since then since i knew i heard him
i was in other school every time if
someone got hurt you would jump in i i
was i was always there
it's good yes thank you brother thank
you man
[Applause]
[Applause]
the reason the reason i cut that short
before going deeper into him
and kind of let him off the hook
is two things one it's very interesting
to see
how much honesty
is a liberator and it was very obvious
to me on that but number two he said
something that i want to finish with
he said
i didn't want to be the person picked on
so i jumped on the weaker link
and i wanted to deflect and if you
listened carefully
the next thing he said was but it still
happened to me
one of the things i believe in the most
in the world is doing the right thing is
always the right thing
and equally on the other side of the
coin doing the wrong thing is always the
wrong thing
we have
a decision to make here today
we have to decide
are you
in a place where you are ready to
actually
shift
and do
and execute on why you're here
all of that
is foundationally on your own
self-awareness of who you are
being okay
that you suck at most things
being accountable
and most importantly
finally cutting out
the cancer of insecurity out of your
body
on the things that have always been
there
by shedding light i wish actual cancer
i wish actual cancer was as easy to cure
as emotional insecurity
emotional insecurity is the biggest
mental cancer in the world
and it is shockingly easy to fix
it is called
putting it out there for some of you
that may be
you're finally ready to actually just do
therapy
and the safest thing for you
is saying out loud
what you feel about your mom or your dad
or your husband or your wife or your
kids that you're embarrassed or scared
to say to anybody else and in the closed
room of a therapy to a stranger
for today
it's the safest place
for others
you might go radical and say [ __ ] it i'm
going to do what gary vee just said on
stage and i'm going to literally post it
everywhere
and there will be a lot of pain with
that
there'll be collateral damage
but you're ready
for others you'll find a different way
whether it's meditation or exercise or
eating differently or journaling or a
million other things that you've heard a
million times
but the reason you're not getting what
you want from it
is you're not being truthful with it
you're protecting yourself
from yourself
yet you're tricking no one
[Music]
please always remember that thank you
[Music]